WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE I AM
WAITING FOR ONE MORE COMMITTEE
MEMBER IN ORDER TO.
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE SO I
BEG YOUR INDULGENCE IT'S THEM
ONE OF THOSE REALLY BUSY DAYS
AND. I'M NOT TRYING TO GET ONE
MORE COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO.
I WILL START SOON
SO IT LOOKS LIKE.
THEY LOOKS LIKE WE'RE READY TO
START IS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
WELCOME TO.
VICE CHAIRMAN MADE.
MATHIS.
HE.
SO I'M WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO TODAY IS WE
HAVE NINE BILLS ON THE AGENDA.
AND THE BELLS ARE HEARD IN FILE
ORDER I WOULD LIKE TO ASK EACH
OF THE AUTHOR TO HAVE BEEN NO
MORE THAN THREE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE TABLE. AND THE OP
OF THE OPPOSITION IS WELL IN
EACH WITNESS WILL BE GIVEN TWO
MINUTES.
.
AND THENAFTER THAT IF YOU COULD
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND.
IN YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL SO
WILL START.
WITH MISTER BIGELOW NUMBER
THREE ON THE AGENDA AB TWENTY
ONE FOURTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ACTUALLY
MANAGER WITH A LITTLE LEVITY FOR
THE DAY BECAUSE IT'S AN
AFTERNOON.
A FRIEND OF MINE ASKED ME TO
START OFF LIKE THIS.
MY FELLOW MEMBERS.
I AM HERE TODAY TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BAIL TO WANT ONE FOR.
AND THAT'S ALL I AGREED TO DO.
IT CAN BE FUNNY AT TIMES SO
LITTLE LEVITY IS GOOD.
ANYWAY THIS MEASURE IS A
SPONSORED A MEASURE BY THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION.
AND I PROVIDE SEVERAL CHANGES TO
THE FOOD AND AG CODE.
AB TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN WILL
EXPAND THE LIMITED EXEMPTION TO
ALLOW A MOBILE PROCESS OPERATOR
TO HARVEST IT. A PURCHASED
ANIMAL FOR THE CONSUMER ON THE
LIVESTOCK PRODUCERS PROPERTY.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL INCLUDES
AN INDUSTRY SUPPORTED FEE
INCREASE FOR BRAIN INSPECTORS TO
RECOVER COSTS.
AND FINALLY AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN WILL ALLOW THE CDF A.
TO ACCEPT ANNUAL PERMIT TO
REENTER THE STATE. CURRENTLY THE
PRODUCERS HAVE TO FIND A BRAND
INSPECTOR FROM ANOTHER STATE TO
CONDUCT AN INSPECTION PRIOR TO
RE ENTRY. THIS CAN BE BURDENSOME
AND SOMETIMES EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS JUST AN
ALL FILLED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION A
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. IT WITH
YOUR INDULGENCE WOULD WE ALLOW
HIM TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JUST
NOT FEEL OF CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION I WILL
MAKE THIS BRIEF.
KNOWING YOU HAVE OTHER ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA JUST A COUPLE POINTS
I WANT TO MAKE.
IN ADDITION TO.
SOME OF EMBRYOS COMMENTS ON THE.
INSPECTION FOR MOBILE SLOUGHED
SLAUGHTER OPERATOR I JUST WANTED
TO CLARIFY THAT.
THE ANIMAL THAT'S HARVESTED ON
THE PROPERTY ULTIMATELY HAS TO
STILL GO TO A STATE LICENSE FOR
USDA INSPECTED FACILITY TO BE
PROCESSED.
AND ALSO.
THE MEAT CAN ONLY BE CONSUMED
BY THE BUYER.
COULD NOT BE SOLD AT RETAIL.
OR BE SOLD YOU KNOW ANY OTHER
WAY.
AND THEN ON THE FEE IT IS AN
INDUSTRY SUPPORT FEE I IT IT
DOES SEEK TO.
HELP.
THE PUREFLEX LIKE ID RECOVER
SOME COSTS.
WHEN INSPECTING SMALLER LOTS OF
CATTLE SO ESSENTIALLY.
THEY'LL BE HIGHER FEE ON YOU
KNOW ONE OR TWO HAD THAT MIGHT
BE INSPECTED AND AND A SMALLER
FEE.
ON ON A HUNDRED CATTLE THAT ARE
INSPECTED IT STILL COST THE SAME
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR THE BUREAU
INSPECTOR TO GO OUT TO THAT
FACILITY.
AND SO BUT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT NOW WE DO SUPPORT WE HAVE A
RESOLUTION ON THE BOOKS TO.
TO SUPPORT THAT SO ANYWAYS I
WOULD ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THINK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SEEING NO MOVEMENT IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
NO OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THIS.
MR MATHIS.
MISTER BIGELOW ODD CAN ALSO
SPEAK WITH GOOD ACTION LOT THAT.
LATE WITH THAT AT ALL SO IF WE
HAD A.
QUORUM HERE I'D* MOVE THE
BILL.
BUT I WILL ASK TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR GOODS.
AND DO THAT.
VERY GOOD.
.
HOPEFULLY THAT ENDS OUR OUR
ATTEMPTS TO BE.
VERY RURAL TODAY AB YOU MAY KEEP
YOU MAKE THAT YOU MAY CONCLUDE
AT YEAH THIS BILL DOES.
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE GET AT A QUORUM OBVIOUSLY
WILL.
I MADE MY COMMITMENTS AND AND I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND ASKED
THE MEMBERS FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MR ARAMBULA.
YOU ARE AT.
I AM NUMBER FIVE ON THE AGENDA
WITCHES AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
EIGHT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY EIGHT. WHICH IS A
BILL THAT WOULD MAKE IT
UNLAWFUL.
TO MAINTAIN AN APIARY THAT IS
NOT REGISTERED AND WOULD CHANGE
THE NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS TO
THE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER.
CURRENTLY ANY PERSON RELOCATING
A COLONY OF BEES
FOR ARE REGISTERED APIARY AND
ONE COUNTY TO ANOTHER COUNTY
SHALL NOTIFY THE DESTINATION
COUNTY AG COMMISSIONER WITHIN
FIVE DAYS.
THIS NOTIFICATION IS CRITICAL TO
PROVIDE THE COMMISSIONER WITH AN
ACCURATE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
LOCATION OF THE BEES TO USE AS A
DETERMINING FACTOR. WHEN ISSUING
USE PERMITS FOR PESTICIDE
APPLICATION.
THAT PERMIT CONDITIONS WILL
TYPICALLY INCLUDE DATE TIME AND
SPECIAL CONDITIONS IMPOSED BY
THE COMMISSIONER THAT MUST BE
ADHERED TO. BY A CERTIFIED
APPLICATOR.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT WILL
IMPROVE INFORMATION BY ENSURING
THE COMMISSIONER HAS THE MOST
UPDATED INFORMATION. APPROVED IT
IN A PESTICIDE USE PERMIT OF A
PESTICIDE HARMFUL DEBBIE'S NEAR
AN APIARY CAN BE AVOIDED.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
COMMISSIONERS WITH CIVIL PENALTY
AUTHORITY TO ASSIST WITH
INCREASING COMPLIANCE WITH
EXISTING STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
TO REGISTER WITH THE COUNTY AG
COMMISSIONER. WHEN THE
TRANSPORTING APIARY COLONY INTO
THE COUNTY.
CIVIL ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES
ARE A COMMON TOOL ALREADY USED
BY COUNTY AG COMMISSIONERS.
THE CURRENT FRAMEWORK ALLOWS FOR
THE APPEALS PROCESS BEFORE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE JUDGE PRIOR TO
THE PENALTY BEING IMPOSED.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO REDUCE THE
TIME TO REGISTER FROM FIVE DAYS
TO SEVENTY TWO HOURS. IN AN
ATTEMPT TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
AND ACCURACY OF LOCATION
INFORMATION.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
MATT SO SILVERLINK FROM THE
CALIFORNIA AG COMMISSIONERS.
BECAUSE WELL AS RICK THE RULE
OUT THE TEHAMA COUNTY AG
COMMISSIONER.
RIVER.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONS ASSOCIATION MY NAME
IS RICK COROLLA TEHAMA COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER.
SO WHAT I'M HERE TODAY IS TO
ASK SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THAT
WILL ALLOW CALTRAIN AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO BETTER TO BE ABLE TO
BETTER DO OUR OUR JOB TO PROTECT
BEEKEEPERS.
LAST FISCAL YEAR.
STATEWIDE.
WE EXPANDED FROM OUR COUNTY NET
NET GENERAL FUND SO ONE MILLION
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED TWELVE DOLLARS.
ENFORCING BE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AS WELL AS.
LOCAL ORDINANCES.
AND.
WILLIE BROWN AND SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN DOLLARS.
WITH WITH THE ONSET OF
INCREASED TECHNOLOGY ADVANCES
ALLOWING US TO ELECTRONICALLY
MAP BEES WILL ALLOW US TO BETTER
PROTECT THE BEES AND AND UP
PREVENT BE LOSSES IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITHIN ANDERSON WITH CAPTAIN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION A PEST
CONTROL ADVISERS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH PICASSO OVER THE
LAST YEAR.
ON A PROJECT CALLED BE WHERE.
AS RICK WAS MENTIONING THE
TECHNOLOGY TO BE ABLE TO
INTEGRATE AND.
AND COMMUNICATE BETTER IN THE
FIELD BETWEEN STAKEHOLDERS THAT
PCA'S WHICH WE REPRESENT THE
APPLICATORS THE COMMISSIONERS
AND BEEKEEPERS I'M SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A.
MORE ROBUST SYSTEM TO PROTECT.
OUR POLLINATORS ESPECIALLY
AROUND ALMOND BLOOM THANK YOU.
THINK YOU'RE MUCH.
HOLLY FOR MANY WITH LIGHT HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIPHATE CALIFORNIA STATE
BEEKEEPERS ASSOCIATION WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BALLOT OR
WORKING WITH.
LEG AB COMMISSIONERS ON AND
FORCE THE MECHANISMS IN LANGUAGE
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
IF YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MATTHEW
CYBERLINK BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER SINCE YOUR
DISSOCIATION AND OUGHT TO BE
REPETITIVE ESTO.
WHAT MR GROW RD TESTIFIED TO
YOU BUT WE'RE WORKING WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS HERE TO PUT IN
A REGULATORY SCHEME TO ENFORCE A
SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY UNDER
CURRENT LAW TO REGISTER THE AYE
COMMISSIONER ME COMING IN THE
COUNTY YOU BUSINESS IS A
COMMERCIAL? PAPER I WOULD HOPE
THAT THIS.
PRESENCE OF A CIVIL PENALTY
WOULD INCREASE THAT COMPLIANCE
RATE HELP US UNDERSTAND WHERE
THESE PEOPLE ARE. AND WHETHER
DOING THEIR WORK SO WE CAN KEEP
THEM SAFE AND.
PROTECT BEAST WHICH WILL WANT
TO. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GEORGE
SOURIS ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL AIRCRAFT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD THING NO OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
GALLAGHER.
HE HAD JUST VERY BRIEFLY MADAM
CHAIR OWES DISCUSS IS ALWAYS
GOOD TO SEE.
COMMISSIONER GROW UP FOR MY
DISTRICT.
AND.
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS A.
A GOOD BILL AND NECESSARY MOVE
FORWARD ALSO YOU KNOW. ARE I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT IN OUR
OUR. BEEKEEPING INDUSTRY A VERY
IMPORTANT TO CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE.
AS AS MANY WILL TELL YOU AND SO
I THINK THIS IS ALL PART AND
PARCEL OF THAT AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
GOOD ANYONE ELSE.
I JUST HAVE A QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO THE M. MISUMI THAT AT
SOME POINT IT BECOMES.
A LITTLE BIT EASIER IF THERE'S
AN APP THAT'S CREATED WHERE YOU
CAN JUST TARGET WHERE YOU'RE
LOCATED IS THAT. IT YEAH I ALSO
KNOW THAT WE HAVE SOME
LIMITATIONS IN RIGA CARDS TO
BROADBAND.
A IT IS THEIR WORK HAPPENING TO
TRY TO MAKE IT EASIER. I GUESS
IN MY MY PITCHES I ALWAYS HATE
TO.
TO BE PUTTING A BURDEN ON AN
INDUSTRY THAT.
THAT IS A SMALL BUSINESS BUT
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
REALLY TO PROTECT THAT INDUSTRY.
AND SO THAT IS KIND OF A
MARRIAGE BETWEEN. TELLING THEM
YOU HAVE TO DO SOMETHING IN
ORDER TO KEEP THEM SAFE AND THEN
ALSO MAKING IT EASY FOR THEM TO
DO IT.
SO I THINK REGISTRATION
OBVIOUSLY IS ALWAYS AVAILABLE
RIGHT THERE IN THE AG
COMMISSIONERS DEPARTMENT BUT.
CAP IS BEEN WORKING WITH
INDUSTRY.
TO INTEGRATE INTO SOME OF THE
FIELD TOWARDS THAT ARE ALREADY
BEING UTILIZED FOR PCA'S
APPLICATORS AND WE BE AND ABLE
TO INTEGRATE THE BEE KEEPER
INTERFACE INTO THAT AS WELL. AND
IT FLOWS INTO GALLON PERMITS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATIONS.
VERY GOOD. AND AND I COULD OUT
ON THAT WE HAVE A VERY
ANTIQUATED SYSTEM WHEREBY AG
COMMISSIONER'S STAFFERS AT
LITTLE USING A PEN ON A CORK
BOARD NOT TO MAP THESE BEES.
WITH A WITH A RECENT. ENACTMENT
OF THE REGULATION OF FOR PRESS
AYE NOTIFICATION AROUND SCHOOLS
WE HAVE A.
NEW ELECTRONIC MAPPING SYSTEM
TO ALLOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO
PIGGYBACK ON THAT SYSTEM TO BE
ABLE TO ACT REALLY MAPPER BEE
HIVES AND WE DEDICATED.
CALIFORNIA COMMISSIONS
ASSOCIATION HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO WORK WITH
OUR SOFTWARE VENDOR TO TO
FURTHER THAT ENDEAVOR THAT'S
GREAT.
THAT'S GOOD I'M GLAD TO HEAR
THAT AND I'M ENTITIES ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION THAT WAS
ACTUALLY AT THE ASSOCIATION'S
CONCERN AS WELL IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SOFTWARE AND
MAKING IT JUST EASIER. SPECIAL
ARE MOVING FROM ONE COUNTY TO
THE OTHER IF WE COULD JUST DO IT
SIMPLY ON AN OUTFIT ON AN IPHONE
RATHER THAN HAVING TO. FAX
THINGS AND THE OLD METHOD THAT
WAS WHY THEY WERE I'M VERY OPEN
TO SUPPORTING THIS BELT BECAUSE
THIS OFFER SYSTEM APPEARS TO BE
REALLY RIGHT ON THE HORIZON.
GREAT.
YOU CAN SAY SOUNDS LIKE YOU GUYS
OF FEAR NOT A GREAT WAY TO GIVE
THE COMMISSIONERS ARE VERY SOME
MORE TOOLS TO LOBBY SAFE.
YOU MAKE INCLUDE.
WELL IF I CAN BE SERIOUS ABOUT
WHAT ONE UC I THANK YOU FOR BE
LEAVING AND. SPELL AND HUMBLY
REQUEST YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
IT WHEN WE GET A QUORUM WILL.
TAKE THIS SEPARATED DOES ENJOY
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SO.
.
I'M LOOKING AROUND I DON'T SEE
ANY OTHER AUTHORS AM I CAN
PROCESS AND ON BEHALF OF. MISTER
RODRIGUEZ TO KEEP US MOVING
HERE.
SALT ALTERNATES OVER.
YOU.
HE LIKES TO
.
THE AFTERNOON MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY WILL HELP
FACILITATE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND FOOD BANKS.
BY REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ESTABLISH GUIDELINES AND BEST
PRACTICES FOR SUCH PARTNERSHIPS.
THESE GUIDELINES WOULD CONSIST
OF INFORMATION ON FOOD HANDLING
REGULATIONS RECOMMENDATIONS ON
FOOD AND COST CONTROL AND AN
EXAMPLE OF WRITTEN PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENT.
FOOD BANKS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO FIGHT CHILD
FOOD INSECURITY. BY PROVIDING
GUIDANCE AND INFORMATION AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY WILL TAKE US
ONE STEP CLOSER TO ENDING HAD A
HUNGER IN CALIFORNIA.
THANKFULLY AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON TAYLOR RUSSIAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION BUT WE ARE SUPPORTED IN
CONCEPT.
OUR GROWERS RECOGNIZE THAT
LIABILITY CAN BE A HUGE
DETERRENT FOR MAKING DONATIONS
TO FOOD BANKS AND SCHOOLS. AND
AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT BETTER
EDUCATION OF BOTH PARTIES WILL
ALLOW FOR GREATER CONSUMPTION OF
CALIFORNIA BASED PRODUCTS AND
CREATE LIFELONG LEADERS THINKS.
THANKS LADY BIRD REPRESENTING
AMERICAN KENNY PEDIATRICS'S WELL
SCHOOL NURSES WERE IN SUPPORT.
MILLION.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
.
PLEASE LET THE OTHER KNOW I I
THINK THIS IS A FANTASTIC BILL.
WE DO A LOT OF THIS IN MY LOCAL
AREA.
INTO PARTNERSHIPS FOR THE FOOD
BANKS IN THE SCHOOL SO I'M I'M
GLAD TO SEE THIS FORWARD IN.
ONE SIDE WE HAVE A QUORUM MADAM
CHAIR WE WILL MOVE FORWARD THANK
YOU FUNDS GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I SEE WE HAVE ANOTHER AUTHOR
HERE MISTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL AB TWENTY NINE
OH NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
IT'S AN HONOR TO PRE HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE ON I KNOW
NINE A FIRST ONE I THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR BEING SO
HELPFUL. ARE MUCH APPRECIATED.
IN THE WAKE OF CALIFORNIA'S
FARM TO FORK MOVEMENT CONSUMER
DEMAND FOR LOCAL AND SMALL FARM
PRODUCTS HAS SKYROCKETED. IN
RESPONSE FARMERS CHEFS FOOD
PURCHASERS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE LOOK FOR
PATHWAYS TO SHORTEN THE SUPPLY
LINE BETWEEN THE PRODUCER. AND
THE CONSUMER SO THAT WE CAN
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
FRESH AND LOCALLY GROWN FOOD.
THIS BILL SUPPORT SMALL SCALE
POULTRY PRODUCERS AND DECREASES
A NUMBER OF MILES BETWEEN FARM
AND FORK.
AB TWENTY NINE OH NINE GIVE
SMALL SCALE POULTRY PRODUCERS
LEEWAY IN EXPANDING THEIR
BUSINESSES BY MAKING SURE THE
FOOD SAFETY REQUIREMENTS ARE
FOLLOWED.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
FOR FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH OFFICERS JUST IN MILAN A
SHIFT DUSKY ES IST ESTES DUST.
AND POULTRY POULTRY PRODUCER
RICHARD COME TUESDAY.
.
SPEC WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
JUST MULLIN FOR THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH DIRECTIVES
WE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL I THINK THE RATIONALE
BEHIND THIS IS TO ACTUALLY HELP
BOTH. THE PRODUCES AND THE
REGULATORS UNDERSTAND WOULDN'T
APPROVE SOURCES RIGHT NOW PART
OF THE PROBLEM IS BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T GO THROUGH THE FEDERAL
INSPECTION PROCESS.
SOME OF THE.
HEALTH INSPECTORS STOP THIS
PRODUCT FROM BEING SOLD AT THE
RETAIL STORE RETAIL LEVEL
WHETHER IT'S THE FARMER'S MARKET
TO ANY OF THE PLACE LIKE THAT.
BY HAVING A PROCESS IN PLACE
THAT CLEARLY THE INDUSTRY
SUPPORTS LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
WILL BE ABLE TO. ACCEPT THIS AS
AN APPROVED SOURCE ANYONE HAVE
ANY HASSLES IN SELLING IT AT.
THOSE RETAIL OUTLETS SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORTED IT IT
ECHOES THAT.
PROCESS WE SET UP A FEW YEARS
AGO WHO COMMUNITY SUPPORTED
AGRICULTURE CSA'S SOBRE VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT AND THANK THE.
THE OATH OF FOR BRINGING
FORWARD.
HI AM DUSKY ESTES I'M CO CHEF
PROPRIETOR OF ZAZU KITCHEN
IMPRIME AND BLACK PIGMEAT CHO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN WOOD FRAME
BITING US HERE TODAY AND FOR
TRULY LISTENING TO THE SMALL
FARMERS AND OUR STATE.
MY HUSBAND AND I HAVE BEEN IN
BUSINESS FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS WE
FARM IN THREE PLACES IN CINEMA
COUNTY. AND WE BUY DIRECT FROM
OVER TWO HUNDRED FARMERS
WE HAVE TO LAMB GUYS ONE GOAT
GUY.
A ONE DUCK GUY WHO'S IN THE ROOM
ONE EGG LADY SIX PICK GUYS TO
PEACH LADIES ONCE ROBBERY AYE
THREE APPLE PEOPLE AND THE LIST
GOES ON.
THERE ARE MORE AND MORE
CONSUMERS DEMANDING TO KNOW THE
FACE THAT FEEDS YOU PARTICULARLY
IN CALIFORNIA.
OVER THE YEARS THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS I CONSISTENTLY HAVE
SEEN THE LOSS OF SMALL FARMERS.
IT BECAUSE IT'S TOO HARD TO MAKE
ENDS MEET.
SOME OF OUR CURRENT POLICIES IN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY MAKE IT
HARDER.
WE'RE THE ONLY STATE IN THE
UNITED STATES BUT DOES NOT ALLOW
SMALL POULTRY PRODUCERS TO HIRE
EMPLOYEES FOR THE HARVEST.
HOW DOES A YOUNG FARMER LEARN
HOW TO DO THIS WITHOUT LEARNING
FROM SOMEBODY WHO'S ALREADY
DOING IT?
AND WHY DO WE HAVE THIS RULE
ANYWAY.
ACCESS TO USDA SLAUGHTER IS ALSO
ONE OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES IN OUR
STATE THERE ONLY THREE USDA
POULTRY SLAUGHTER FACILITIES BUT
WILL PROCESS FOR SMALL FIRMS IN
OUR STATE. AND THIS IS A VERY
BIG STATES.
TRAVEL DISTANCES ARE GREAT AND
THE YEAR LONG WEIGHTLESS
FOR SLAUGHTER ARE TOO LONG.
THERE IS A USDA EXEMPTION FOR
SMALL POULTRY FARMERS THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO SLAUGHTER ON FARM
AND SETTLE TO HOTELS RESTAURANTS
AND INSTITUTIONS BUT CALIFORNIA
DOES NOT TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF
THIS EXEMPTION.
WHAT WHY WHEN WHERE THE GREATEST
AGRICULTURAL STATE AND THE
CREATOR OF THE FARM TO TABLE
MOVEMENT?
CURRENTLY SMALL POULTRY FARMERS
CAN POSSIBLY SELL AT A FARMER'S
MARKET. IF THEY'RE INSPECTOR
INTERPRETS THE REGULATIONS THAT
WAY. AND IT'S DIFFERENT IN EVERY
COUNTY.
AB TWO NINE AND NINE ALLOWS FOR
EMPLOYEES.
AND THAT THE USE OF THE USDA
EXEMPTION FOR SMALL FARMERS TO
SELL DIRECT TO HOTELS AND
RESTAURANTS.
THIS IS NOT LESS SAFE.
WHEN YOU BUY DIRECT.
YOU KNOW THE SOURCE AND THERE'S
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY.
REGARDING FOOD SAFETY AB TWO
NINE NINE NINE ALSO CREATES A
SYSTEM WHERE POULTRY RANCHERS
WHO WANT TO SLAUGHTER ON FARM.
GET TRAINED TO BE THEIR OWN MEAT
INSPECTORS LIKE THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IN PLACE PER CDFA BUTCHER
SHOPS.
MY HUSBAND TAKES A CLASS EACH
YEAR TO BE ARMY INSPECTOR.
IT ALSO CLARIFIES WHAT IS
ALLOWED IN TERMS OF THE HR
EXEMPTION SO THERE'S NO
CONFUSION WITH THE
INTERPRETATION BY DIFFERENT
INSPECTORS AS SOMETIMES HAPPENS
NOW.
AS THE MANY LETTERS OF SUPPORT
MAKE CLEAR.
THERE ARE MANY SHOPS FROM ACROSS
THIS GREAT STATE WHO ARE FOR
THIS BILL.
I SPEAK FOR THEM ALL WHEN I SAY
PLEASE SUPPORT AB TWO NINE NINE
NINE.
SO WHY DID THE CHICKEN CROSS THE
ROAD.
START THEIR LONG JOURNEY TO A
USDA PLANT BECAUSE THEY'RE
FARMER WASN'T ALLOWED TO HARVEST
ON THEIR RANCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RICHARD G.*. AND MY WIFE AND
I OWN AND OPERATE THE WOOKIE
RANCH IN CHICO CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE BEEN FARMING SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY THREE AS YOU
MIGHT HAVE GUESSED WE REYES
PASTURED POULTRY AS WELL SHEEP
AND HOGS.
SINCE THIS HEARING IS ABOUT
POULTRY. I WOULD LIKE TO BRIEFLY
DESCRIBE HARPAL DROP REGIME
WORKS SO YOU CAN ALL BE POULTRY
FARMERS.
THERE ARE FOUR BASIC STEPS
BROODING GROWING HARVESTING IN
MARKETING.
ON DAY ONE WE PICK UP DAY OLD
CHICKS FROM THE POST OFFICE AND
PLACE THEM IN A WARM DRIVE
BRUDER FOR UP TO TWO WEEKS.
AFTER THAT THE CHICKENS GO OUT
ON THE PASTOR TO GROW FOR THE
NEXT FOUR TO FIVE WEEKS.
THAT AN APPROXIMATE FORTY TWO TO
FORTY NINE DAYS THE CHICKENS ARE
HARVESTED ON OUR FARM.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH CURRENT STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW.
FINING THE CHICKENS ARE TAKEN TO
OUR LOCAL FARMERS MARKETS AND
SOLD DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS.
TODAY TO BE EXEMPT FROM BOTH
FEDERAL INSPECTION AND STATE
REGISTRATION.
HOW FAR CAN ONLY GROW ON CROSSES
ONE THOUSAND BIRDS OR LESS
ANNUALLY ADDITIONALLY IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE SOLD AT THE
LOCAL FARMERS MARKET? THOSE
BIRDS NEED TO BE PROCESSED BY
QUOTE IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS
AND QUOTE ONLY. AND CAN ONLY BE
SOLD DIRECTLY TO THE END
CONSUMER. FINALLY IN MODE AND
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY.
THESE ONE THOUSAND BIRDS
PROCESSED ON FARM CURRENTLY HAVE
NO GUARANTEE THAT THEY WILL MEET
WITH APPROVED SOURCE. STATUS
FROM LOCAL COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICIALS ALLOWING THEM TO BE
SOLD AT ALL.
THE CURRENT REGULATIONS ARE
CONFUSING TO MANY WOULD BE
POULTRY PRODUCERS AS WELL AS TO
REGULATORS.
AB TWENTY NINE OH NINE ADDRESSES
THE SHORTCOMINGS.
AB TWENTY NINE OH NINE WILL LIE
A LINE STATE LAW WITH FEDERAL
LAW AND PROVIDE SOME GAIN.
CHANGING BENEFITS OF SMALL SCALE
POULTRY PRODUCERS THE BILL WILL.
ALLOW SMALL SCALE POULTRY.
PRODUCERS CLARITY ON THE
REGULATIONS GOVERNING THE
GROWING HARVESTING IN MARKETING
OF POULTRY.
ALLOW SMALL SCALE PRODUCERS TO
HIRE EMPLOYEES TO HELP WITH
HARVESTING.
ALLOW SMALL SCALE PRODUCERS TO
SELL TO OTHER BUSINESSES WERE
RESULT. AS MEAT OR MEALS
INCLUDING A DISTRIBUTOR HOTEL
RESTAURANT RETAIL STORE
INSTITUTION OR SMALL AND A
PRESENT FROM THE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS QUOTED. PER THE
FEDERAL EXEMPTION.
AMEND THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE
TO DEEM THAT POULTRY MEAT
PRODUCED PURSUANT TO THE
REQUIREMENTS OF AB TWENTY NINE
OH NINE IS FROM THE PROOF
SOURCE.
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THOSE WILL BUY FROM SMALL SCALE
PRODUCERS.
THESE WILL BE TRAINED AS DOES HE
SAID.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY
NINE OH NINE I UNDERSTAND THAT
MY FARM WILL HAVE TO REGISTER
WITH THE CD FAA AND PAN ANNUAL
FEE.
TAKE CDFA TRAINING.
AND MEET CDFA SANITATION AND
TRACEABILITY GUIDELINES
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS APPROACH
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT AB TWENTY
NINE OH NINE. WILL PROVIDE HUGE
BENEFITS TO SMALL SCALE POULTRY
PRODUCERS CONSUMERS AND
REGULATORS ALIKE.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND CAN
ANSWER ANY QUESTION ABOUT
CHICKENS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
BENJAMIN PALMER ON BEHALF OF
MARIN COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
MICHALEK TO CHANGE WE'RE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CATHERINE QUAN BACK THE NICHE
MEAT PROCESSOR SYSTEMS NETWORK
AT TRADE ORGANIZATION FOR SMALL
PROCESSORS IN SUPPORT.
KELLY AS MEN US FAMILY FARM.
WE REYES HERITAGE PASSED YOUR
TURKEY HERITAGE PASTURE DUES
HERITAGE RABBITS AND PASTURE
DAK.
THIS BILL WILL HELP US TO BE
MORE.
SUSTAINABLE MORE PROFITABLE AND
MORE VIABLE I ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS WE BRING A SMALL
FARMERS TO THE MARKETPLACE WHICH
BIG BAG CANNOT AND THAT'S FLAVOR
AND HERITAGE.
THANK YOU.
PATRICK MULVANEY MULVANEY ES
RESTAURANT NAMED SEGMENT ON
SPORT BILL.
JIM RACKARD AYE ON CINEMA COUNTY
POULTRY LIBERTY DUCKS EXPORT
THIS BILL. TO GIVEN THE PAST US
SO MANY FFA MEMBERS FOR EACH
MEMBERS STARTED THEIR
BUSINESSES.
WITHOUT THIS BILL THEY HAVE NO
WAY OF GETTING TO THAT POINT.
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
I AIR GLOBAL MILLER I'M THE
ONER AT THE MILLER MEETS IN THE
SACRAMENTO HOLE AND ALL BUT YURI
AND WE FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE IN OPPOSITION
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE. YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
JUST EVERITT RESPECT WEST EUROPE
AYE VOTE IF YOU WANT TO SEE A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF WHAT PEOPLE CAN
DO WITH WITH SOME OF FOOD FROM
SMALL FARMERS WHETHER IT'S
WHETHER IT'S LIVESTOCK ORDER.
OR FRUITS VEGETABLES IT'S OZZIE
AND THESE PEOPLE ARE AMAZING AND
HAVE BEEN IN BUSINESS FOR A LONG
TIME AND.
.
PART OF THE BIG PART OF OUR FOOD
MOVEMENT IN CINEMA COUNTY AND I
THANK THEM FOR EVERYTHING THEY
DO.
IT'S GREAT WELL THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE TODAY APPRECIATED
VERY MUCH THIS BILL DOES.
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
I THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO GET
A QUORUM BUT WE'RE STILL ONE
SHORT SO ONCE WE GET A QUORUM
WILL START WORKING ON THESE
BILLS. VERY MUCH TYPICALLY SO
MUCH.
AND.
WE'RE ACTUALLY DOING REALLY WELL
AYE WE IF WE CAN GET.
THE LAST COUPLE OF AUTHORS HERE.
AND MR MATHIS BACK THEN WE CAN
JUST A SLAM THROUGH THESE.
SO WE'RE DOWN TO THE LAST.
TO.
WE HAVE TWO MORE BILLS AND THEN
THE CONSENT.
AGENDA ITEMS.
YOU WANT A FEW QUICK THE SPEECH
BY HEIGHT NO.
WE MAY GET THERE. VERY SOON SOON
WHY
I REMEMBER
MR THURMAN WELCOME.
I'M I'M IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING
TO GET A M..
QUORUM.
BUT DAMN YOU MAY PUT YOU MAY
PERCENT.
YES ABSOLUTELY.
I WILL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN E. B. THIRTY ONE FIFTY
NINE I HAVE NO WHERE TO BE BUT
WHERE YOU WANT ME MADAM CHAIR
I'M HERE FOR AS LONG AS YOU
WANT.
YOU MAY PROCEED PERCENT PRESENT
NOW THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB THIRTY
ONE FIFTY NINE.
A BILL THAT WILL POSITION
CALIFORNIA AS A LEADER AS IT
RELATES TO YOU HUMANE POULTRY
SLAUGHTER PRACTICE.
I DON'T THINK THE CHAIR AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL.
THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST IN
THIS BILL ON ALL SIDES. AND.
WE ARE COMMITTED THE DEFINING
WORKABLE WAYS TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD. AND WE THINK THAT WE'VE
LANDED ON SOLUTIONS THAT CAN CAN
WORK. OUT WE HAVE HEARD THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT ON SMALL
BUSINESSES AND WE ARE PROPOSING
A SOLUTION. A AND HAVE SHARED
THE SOLUTION THAT WE THINK WILL
WORK. AND I'M COMMITTED TO A
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
AYE IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
SPECIFICALLY CALLING FOR A
STATE FUND TO AID SMALL FALLERS
SMALL I'M SORRY SMALL FARMERS
TO.
COMPLY WITH WHAT THIS BILL
PURPORTS TO DO.
I PROPOSED AMENDING THE BILL
ALONG AND WORKING WITH THE CHAIR
AND HER STAFF.
CREATE A FUND THAT ALLOW STATE
AND PRIVATE DOLLARS TO MAKE
EQUIPMENT UPGRADES ZERO COSTS
SMALL BUSINESSES.
NO WE WILL CONDITION THE NEW
REGULATIONS ON THE AVAILABILITY
OF STATE FUNDS.
EVEN AT THE MOST EXPENSIVE WE
ESTIMATE.
OF THAT TWO THOUSAND AND NEW
EQUIPMENT FOR SIXTY FARMS.
WOULD BE CIRCA HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
FIGURE THAT WE THINK.
IS WITHIN MEANS.
FOR THE LEADERSHIP OF OF THIS
HOUSE IN A THAT WE CAN.
WORK WITH.
.
I WANT TO BE REALLY CLEAR ON ONE
THING THAT.
.
YOU KNOW.
SEE FOR MYSELF I I'M NOT A
VEGETARIAN I'M NOT A VEGAN.
I ENJOY EATING MEAT AND.
I HAVE NO DESIRE TO SEE. ANY
NEGATIVE IMPACT TO THE POULTRY
INDUSTRY.
IT DOES NOT SERVE MY PURPOSES I
DON'T THINK IT SERVES ANYONE'S
PURPOSES OR CALIFORNIA'S
PURPOSES.
AND AND IT IS WITH THAT.
.
APPROACH THAT I HOPE YOU WILL
EXPECT SET.
WHAT IT IS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE?
I'VE HAD WITH ME TODAY A
WITNESS FROM THE HUMANE SOCIETY
WISHES TO. OFFER A LITTLE BIT
MORE EMPHASIS HERE.
ADDUCTOR SARA SHIELDS IN IF YOU
WOULD. WELCOME HER.
HOW ARE WITNESSES?
?
IT'S STUCK IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
BUT WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE THAT
RESPECT WE ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
THANKS VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IS THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
BUT THEN IT.
IF I IF I COULD JUST A MINUTE IT
LOOKS LIKE MAYBE THE WITNESS IT
WAS GOING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
JUST WALKED IN. A RELEASE IS
HERE BUT WE ARE HAPPY TO.
WHEN IT WENT AWAY TO LET HER
TAKE THAT SEAT RIGHT THERE AND
THEN REALLY GO AHEAD AND. KEEP
YOURS AND THEN WILL PROCEED
AFTERWARDS.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. IF YOU MADAM CHAIR
A DOCTOR SHARE SHIELDS ARE
WITNESS FROM THE HUMANE SOCIETY.
I'M I'M SERIOUS SHIELDS HAVE.
BEHAVIOR AND WELFARE SPECIALIST
FOR HUMANE SOCIETY INTERNATIONAL
AND I DID MY DOCTORAL WORK AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. ON
POULTRY BEHAVIOR AND WELFARE.
I AM THERE SIMPLY NO BIOLOGICAL
REASON TO EXEMPT POULTRY FROM
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THEY BE
RENDERED UNCONSCIOUS PURCHASE
SHACKLING.
HANGING A BIRD IN AN INVERTED
POSITION IS AND PHYSIOLOGICALLY
ABNORMAL POSTURE FOR. A BIRD AND
YOU CAN TAKE A BLOOD SAMPLE AND
MEASURE A RISE IN STRESS
HORMONES SO WE KNOW IT'S A
STRESSFUL PROCESS FOR THEM.
SHACKLES HAVE TO BE TIGHT
FITTING BUT THE LEGS
CHICKENS VERY AND SO HANGING
OPERATORS CAN USE CONSIDERABLE
FORCE TO PERFECT LEGS INTO
NARROW SHACKLES.
BIRD STRUGGLE ON THE LINE THEY
HAVE NOCICEPTIVE PAIN RECEPTORS
IN THEIR LEGS AND FEET SO WE
KNOW IT'S PAINFUL BRUISING IS
DOCUMENTED.
BROILER CHICKENS ARE PRONE TO
DEBILITATING LAMENESS AND LEG
DISORDERS AND SO WHEN YOU HANG
THEM UPSIDE DOWN YOU ARE
EXACERBATING LIKE PROBLEMS THAT
THEY ARE ALREADY EXPERIENCING.
SO GIVEN OTHER RESEARCH THERE'S
NO GOOD REASON TO EXEMPT POULTRY
AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY NINE SIMPLY
MAKES THE ROLE MORE CONSISTENT.
BY EXTENDING THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE FOR OTHER ANIMALS.
THERE ARE SEVERAL GOOD
ALTERNATIVES THAT CAN BE USED.
AND THERE'S HAD ONLY ELECTRICAL
STANDING THERE'S CAPTIVE BOGAN
STUNNING WITH POULTRY SIZE A
CAPTIVE BOTH GUNS. AND GAS
STUNNING IS ALSO A POTENTIAL
POSSIBILITY. I AM IDEALLY YOU
WOULD WANT THE BIRDS TO BE
RENDERED UNCONSCIOUS BEFORE
TURNING THEM UPSIDE DOWN. BUT
THERE IS A METHOD WHERE YOU CAN
USE A CONE TO PUT THE BIRDS AND
YOU CAN STUN THEM QUICKLY AND
EASILY WITH A CAPTIVE BOTH
STEINER. AND THEY'RE COMPLETELY
UNCONSCIOUS BEFORE YOU EVER
POUNDS BUT THEIR THROAT. AND THE
BENEFIT OF.
DOING THIS IF THERE'S NOT ONLY
AN ANIMAL WELFARE BENEFIT BUT
THERE'S ALSO A POTENTIAL BENEFIT
THIS JOB.
BECAUSE IF THE BIRDS ARE ALREADY
RENDERED ANNOUNCED IN AND
SENSIBLE BEFORE THEY'RE HUNG ON
THE LINE THERE'S LESS FLATTER.
LESS WING FLAPPING LESS DIRT
LESS NOISE LESS EXCREMENT WEST
FEATHER DANDER.
CALIFORNIANS CARE ABOUT ANIMALS
THEY CARE ABOUT ANIMALS ON THE
FARM THE CARROT SLAUGHTER
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE PURCHASING
FROM A LOCAL.
SMALL SCALE PROCESSOR THEY
EXPECT THAT TREATMENT OF THE
ANIMALS TO BE MORE HUMANE. SO WE
FEEL THAT A. B. THIRTY ONE FIFTY
NINE HELPS.
PROCESSORS MEET CONSUMER
EXPECTATIONS FOR HUMANE
TREATMENT OF ANIMALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO LOOKS LIKE WE THINK YOU WRITE
REALLY DO APPRECIATE LOOKS LIKE
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND TAKE ROLE
BECAUSE.
COMEY ARROW THERE. MATHIS HERE.
ADHERE CURRY FLORA GALLAGHER.
GRAY.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
LEVINE SALAS.
OKAY NOW THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM
THERE ARE THREE ITEMS THAT ARE
ON OUR AGENDA AS CONSENT AGENDA
ITEMS NUMBER ONE E. BE. NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES AND ITEM NUMBER EIGHT A.
B. THIRTY TO FIFTY TWO. POP AT
COMMITTEE BILL AND ITEM NUMBER
NINE E. B. THIRTY TO SIXTY WHICH
IS ANOTHER COMMITTEE BILL I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THOSE
THREE.
THE ROW PLEASE.
A.
COMING HERO I'M COMING YEAR I
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE AGUILAR CURRY
FLORA. GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE
GRAY.
GRAY AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE LEVINE SALAS BILLS
ARE OUT OF THE BILL IS OUT AND
SO WILL LEAVE THE ROLL CALL OPEN
FOR. MEMBERS TO ADD ON WILL
RESUME WITH THE HEARING AND.
OPPOSITION.
OH I'M SORRY.
THE IN SUPPORT NICHOLAS SACKETT
REPRESENTS SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION IN SUPPORT ALSO
COURTESY OF SUPPORT FROM HUMANE
SOCIETY UNITED STATES.
AND MERCY FOR ANIMALS.
THANK YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ROBERT SIEGEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND WE ARE OPPOSED AB
THIRTY ONE FIFTY NINE.
FARM BUREAU REPRESENTS NEARLY
FORTY THOUSAND MEMBERS ACROSS
ALL SECTIONS CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION AND BE
VERY CLEAR.
FARM BUREAU STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE HUMANE TREATMENT OF ANIMALS
AND WOULD NEVER CONDONE THEIR
MISSION DID THEIR MISTREATMENT.
WE SUPPORT MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
BUT HUMANE CARE OF LIVESTOCK AND
POULTRY IS DEVELOPED THROUGH
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH. INDUSTRY
TESTED PRACTICES OR SET FORTH IN
THE ANIMAL CARE SERIES PUBLISHED
BY THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE COOP COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT EXISTING
LAW AND EXISTING REGULATIONS
PROMULGATED BY CDFA. CLEARLY
ESTABLISHED ACCEPTABLE AND
PRACTICAL HUMANE METHODS FOR THE
USE OF STUNNING OF POULTRY.
FURTHER ABSENT ANY DATA FROM
CDFA INDICATING A HIGHER
CURRENTS OF GROSS NEGLIGENCE ARE
IN HUMANE SLAUGHTER OF POULTRY
IN CALIFORNIA. WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS COMPRESSIBILITY COMPLETELY
UNNECESSARY.
AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY NINE WILL
HAVE NO IMPACT.
ON THE LARGER SCALE COMMERCIAL
POULTRY OPERATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
FOR THOSE INSPECTED BY USDA.
IN FACT
THE FIFTY FIVE CDFA INSPECTED
FACILITIES MANY OF WHICH ARE
SMALL MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND SOME
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION MEMBERS.
WILL BEAR THE UNNECESSARY
BURDENS
A MEETING THESE REQUIREMENTS
CDFA HAS IN FACT INDICATED TO
COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL OF
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU THAT THIS
LEGISLATION WILL IMPACT ROUGHLY
EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE
BUSINESSES.
THAT ARE ON THE LIST THAT WAS
HANDED OUT RIGHT BEFORE OUR
TESTIMONY.
WE DO NOT BELIEVE IT IS FAIR
THAT THE SMALL BUSINESSES OR OUR
MEMBERS.
MEET NEW REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
THAT OUR DEVELOPED IN A VACUUM
WITHOUT THE EXPERTISE OF CDFA.
WITHOUT BROADER PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT WITH INDUSTRY.
AND WITHOUT DEMONSTRATE THAT
DEMONSTRATING A CLEAR NECESSITY.
THIS BILL ONLY MAKES IT MORE
FINANCIALLY DIFFICULT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S MINORITY BUSINESS
OWNERS HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
INCREASE THE OCCURRENCE OF
WORKPLACE INJURIES AND IN HUMANE
SLAUGHTER AND IGNORES THE IMPACT
THAT THESE BUSINESSES HAVE. IN
RELATION TO SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA FARM TO FORK
MOVEMENT.
AND INCREASING THE AVAILABILITY
OF HEALTHY FOOD PRODUCTS FOR
OTHER CALIFORNIANS.
FOR THESE REASONS CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU RESPECT RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR NO VOTE ON AB THIRTY
ONE FIFTY NINE.
I THINK VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BROUGHT
RECENTLY HAVE CALIFORNIA POULTRY
FEDERATION. WILL ECH THE
COMMENTS THAT THE ROBERT JUST.
OUTLINED FOR THE COMMITTEE.
AGAIN OUR FUNDAMENTAL PROMISES
HE'S
OR OUR BELIEF IS THAT THE
PROMISE IS INCORRECT.
THAT DECISION HUMANE TREATMENT
OF BIRDS OF THIS ACCEPTED
PRACTICE IT HAS BEEN LOOKED AT
SCIENTIFICALLY.
AND IN OUR VIEW.
IS THIS BILL PRESUPPOSES THAT
ONE.
OR MAKE ANY NUMBER OF OTHER
MEASURES.
OF STUNNING ARE MORE HUMANE.
THAT IS NOT BEEN.
WHAT HAS BEEN FOUND
SCIENTIFICALLY?
AND. WE'RE JUST UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH PROMISE AND HAVE TO
STRONGLY POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU.
BUT AIMS JIM REICHARDT AYE ON
CINEMA COUNTY POULTRY AND.
.
I'M SPEAKING ANECDOTALLY.
BECAUSE I I HAVE NO NO
SCIENTIFIC. BEHIND ME BUT MY
FAMILY'S BEEN SLAUGHTERING BIRD
SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY TWO. ANY
OTHER STATE INSPECTED REALIZED
HE A PLAN.
AND BEEN CHUCKLE THE ENTIRE TIME
AND IT'S CRITICAL THAT YOU'RE
THE PERSON HANGING TO BIRDS
NEEDS TO BE TRAINED WELL AND
NEEDS TO BE TREATING THE VIRTUE
MAINLY. BUT PAST THAT I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE SHOWING ANY
SIGNS OF. OF DISCOMFORT.
SO. THEY HAVE TO BE STANDING NOW
ANYHOW.
AND THE SHACKLING IS A VERY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME AND AND
IT'S ACCEPTED.
PRACTICE IT'S NOT.
THE BIRDS DON'T APPEAR TO BE.
GOING THROUGH ANY LARGE AMOUNTS
OF STRESS IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU THINK.
FOR ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTION FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I JUST WANTED BLOOD.
BUT DID THE AUTHOR.
.
TALK ABOUT PROP PROVIDING SOME.
FINANCIAL REMEDY TO THIS AND
AND I KNOW.
.
I WOULD THINK THE INDUSTRY WOULD
MIND GOING TO A MORE HUMANE.
.
WAY OF DOING THIS.
AND SINCE A LOT OF THESE.
INDUSTRIES HAPPEN TO BE MY
DISTRICT. IT'S OF GREAT CONCERN
TO ME THAT. WE AS A LEGISLATURE
DON'T.
CREATE UNDUE ECONOMIC HARM TO
ANYONE WE WE LEGISLATE ALL THE
TIME.
AND.
THE SOMETIMES WE DON'T ALWAYS
LOOK AT THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
IT. ON ENCOURAGE.
THAT THE AUTHOR WOULD LIKE TO
CREATE SOME.
.
SOME WAIT FINANCIALLY ENSURE
THAT THIS INDUSTRY DOESN'T GO
OUT OF BUSINESS
THAT THIS INDUSTRY DOESN'T
BECOME FINANCIALLY.
STRAPPED WITH REGULATIONS THAT
WE. CLING ON I'M IN OWNERS WAY.
AND SO I I I TAKE THE WORD OF
THE AUTHOR THAT HE WILL. WORK
WITH THE INDUSTRY TO TRY TO COME
UP WITH SOME ARM.
BOTTOM. SOME WAYS TO GET THROUGH
THIS ITEM.
FINANCIAL QUAGMIRE AND DUBBED.
AND I I I WILL VOTE FOR TODAY
BUT I WILL. IF IT GETS OUT OF
HERE O. DEFTLY RESERVE.
ANY VOTE ON THE FLOOR.
IF THERE IS NO FINANCIAL.
WAY OF GETTING AROUND THIS.
.
MY VOTE MAY CHANGE DRAMATICALLY.
ANYONE ELSE.
MR MATHIS.
MR THURMAN I.
THEY IS VICE CHAIR OF BAG OF
TRAVEL ALL UP AND DOWN THE
STATE.
AND I'VE VISITED.
MANY FARMS WHERE CHICKENS ARE
GROWN I'VE BEEN THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF OBSCENE.
AND IN THEIR SEVEN DIFFERENT
METHODS THAT ARE AUTHORIZED AND
I'VE PRETTY MUCH SEEN THEM ALL
NOT TO MENTION I'M A COUNTRY BOY
AND I'VE DONE IT THE OLD
FASHIONED WAY.
.
TO.
IN IN MY MIND TO STEP AWAY FROM
THE ELECTRICAL PATH MATH THE.
IT IS KIND OF A STEP BACKWARDS I
MEAN AND IT'S A PROCESS THAT
WORKS IT CLEANS THE BIRD IT
ACTUALLY TAKES DOWN THE DOWNTURN
EVERYTHING ELSE IT IT.
IT THE WE WENT THAT DIRECTION
FOR A REASON.
.
BEAT BECAUSE IT IS A CLEANER
PROCESS.
A I JUST.
TO ME THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IT
DOESN'T ADD UP THERE'S ALREADY
THINGS BEING DONE.
INSTEAD SHE TO OF HAVE AS WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD A A.
THEN IN MISTER THEM IN THIS IS
NOTHING ON THE AYE I THINK THIS
IS MORE THE.
PROPONENTS OF THIS LEGISLATION
I THINK THEY'VE GOT TO SING ON A
WILD GOOSE CHASE MY FRIEND.
PUN INTENDED.
ALL YOU.
POULTRY ALL HERE.
.
IT'S.
THERE'S THERE'S A LOT MORE HERE.
.
THEY A REALLY DID TO BRING IN
THE FINANCIAL BACKING PIECE IT'S
IT'S NOT IN THERE CURRENTLY.
THERE'S NOT AMENDMENTS BEFORE
US.
DAYS.
ALREADY BEEN STATED OF HER ON
THE DIET SAY I THINK. ASKING
ANYBODY TO DO ANYTHING WITHOUT
FUNDING TO BACK UP THIS
COMPLETELY PREPOSTEROUS.
THEY I THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE
HERE.
ON THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE BEFORE
THE SNOW SPORTS ARE NOT GOING TO
BE SUPPORTING TODAY BUT IT'S NOT
AND. I WORK WITH YOU ONE HUNDRED
ONE OTHER THINGS MAN AND WE DO A
LOT OF GOOD WORK.
I JUST DON'T THINK THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT SENT YOU THIS GOT IT
RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
DEGREE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE I THINK
THE INTENT OR THE AUTHOR'S
COMING FROM. ON THIS.
THEY ALWAYS ASK MYSELF WHAT A
BILLS BEFORE US.
HAS THREE BASIC QUESTIONS THE
FIRST MAN IS THEIR PROBLEM.
IF I DECIDE THERE IS THEM.
IT'S JUST A PROBLEM THE STATE
SHOULD SOLVE.
AND. AND IF I GET PAST QUESTION
DO I GET TO DOES THIS BILL
ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISH SOLVING THAT
PROBLEM.
I'M NOT SURE.
I MIGHT YOU STRIKE NOW ALL THREE
OF THOSE QUESTIONS ON THE BILL
BEFORE ME.
BUT AS I HEAR THE DISCUSSION.
AROUND PUT SOME FINANCES YOU
HYPER ALTERNATIVE METHODS IN
THIS AND THAT.
WHAT IS THE QUESTION I HAVE FOR
THE AUTHORS?
WHY WOULDN'T YOU HAVE APPROACH
THIS ISSUE?
BY CREATING AND AND. A CARROT UP
A FUND TO.
.
VOLUNTARILY OFFER FOR THE STATE
TO OFFER TO.
FOLKS WANT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
CHANGING A METHOD SERVE OR
IMPLEMENTING NEW. TECHNOLOGY
THAT SEEMS LIKE A WAY TO GET
AFTER THE PROBLEM ON A VOLUNTARY
BASIS.
.
BUT THE BILL BEFORE ME JUST
SEEMS.
.
MISPLACED IN THE IN THE WAY IT
GOES ABOUT SOME PROPS ARE ALL
THAT YOU ARE RESPOND.
ARE THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
I DON'T THINK THAT WE'RE PASSED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE
INCENTIVES AND WE'RE OPEN TO
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
INDUSTRY AND. WITH YOU KNOW
FARMERS AND WITH THOSE WHO HAVE
ALL KINDS OF EXPERIENCE AND I
THINK. THAT THERE IS STILL THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR.
AN INCENTIVE CONVERSATION.
I I WOULD SAY THIS AND IT YOU
KNOW I DO NOT QUESTION THE
EXPERIENCE OF ANYONE AND I'M NOT
SAYING THAT I HAVE THAT
EXPERIENCE I DON'T.
I DO KNOW THIS.
THAT A MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS.
HAVE ASKED
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE
HUMANE A USES AS RELATES TO
SLAUGHTER PALTRY.
AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT THAT THIS
IS THE DIRECTION OF THE INDUSTRY
HAS HAS MOVED IN.
AND.
I ALSO ACCEPT THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE OF. PROVISIONS
HELP THE SMALLER.
COMPANIES THAT DON'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO ABSORB WHAT LARGE
COMPANIES CAN AND AND I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
AND SO.
WE'RE BEING CREATIVE IN OUR
APPROACH IN SAYING THAT WE WILL
PROVIDE DOLLARS TO DO THAT TO
OFFSET THAT COST TO MAKE IT IS
ZERO.
OFFSET.
AND IF WE CAN ACHIEVE THAT AS
YOU SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAP THIS
WE WORK TOGETHER. A HUNDRED AND
ONE TIMES ON THINGS THAT YOU ALL
KNOW ME IF I SAY I'M GONNA DO
SOMETHING I DO IT. AND IF I
CAN'T DO IT YOU WILL HAVE TO
CHANGE YOUR VOTE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER BECAUSE I WOULD
WITHDRAW THE BILL BEFORE DOING
THAT.
BECAUSE WHEN I SAY I'M GONNA DO
SOMETHING THAT'S HOW I CARRY
MYSELF. AS I SAID AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
DATA CALIFORNIANS OVERWHELMINGLY
HAVE SAID THAT THEY WILL LIKE TO
SEE. MORE HUMANE PRACTICES AS IT
RELATES TO THE SLAUGHTER OF
POULTRY WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO IT. AT IN MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION WE'VE UNCOVERED THAT
FOR SOME BUSINESSES MANY OF THEM
SMALL MINORITY WHO I CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT. THAT THEY WOULD BE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED AND SO NOW
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
OFFSET THEIR COSTS.
WHY WOULDN'T WE TAKE THAT ACTION
IS WHAT I WOULD SAY TO YOU WHY
WOULD IT WHEN? WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A WIN A WIN AND
A WIN WHERE EVERYONE WINS AND AS
I'VE SAID. IF I CAN'T DELIVER ON
WHAT I PROPOSE.
YOU WON'T HAVE TO CHANGE YOUR
VOTE
BECAUSE I WON'T PUT IT BEFORE
YOU IN ANOTHER FORMAT SO I AM
ASKING YOU TODAY. FOR YOUR VOTE
I'M ASKING YOU TODAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY TO SEE THAT THERE IS
A YES BEHIND THOSE THREE
QUESTIONS THAT THERE IS A
CHALLENGE IT CALIFORNIA'S A BASS
US. TO ADDRESS THAT THE STATE
HAS A ROLE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LIFT UP SOME ADDITIONAL BEST
PRACTICES AND IF THE STATE'S
GOING TO CREATE A REGULATION AND
AS A WAY TO PROVIDE DOLLARS TO
DO THAT. THE STATE SHOULD DO
THAT THE BEAUTY OF IT IS THERE
ARE MANY IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
WHO HAVE OFFERED TO STEP UP TO
HELP TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN SO IT'S
NOT ALL JUST ON THE STATE'S
DONE.
SO THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR
INCENTIVE THERE'S OPPORTUNITY
FOR GOVERNMENT DOLLARS AND THIS
OPPORTUNITY FOR PRIVATE DOLLARS
THE ONE TO MAKE THIS A REALITY.
AND. I THINK WE CAN CREATE A
DEEP PARTNERSHIP IN HOW WE TALK
ABOUT THIS I WANT. THE FOLKS
FROM INDUSTRY TO BE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THIS CONVERSATION.
THIS IS NOT TO BE A BLAME GAME
THIS CAN BE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW WE TOGETHER CAN MAKE
SOMETHING EFFECTIVELY HAPPEN.
THINK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'LL TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOSING.
YES I'D BE HAPPY TO MAKE THEM I
CLOSE.
UNLESS SOMEONE HAS ANOTHER
QUESTION FROM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THINK YOU THINK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE SAYS ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SO MR THURMAN WE HAD A LONG
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS AND.
AYE AYE THAT IN IN REALITY WHAT
I HEAR THE INDUSTRY SAYING IS
THAT.
IS THAT THIS MAY NOT BE THE
MOST HUMANE. AND THEY'RE NOT
SURE THAT THE SCIENCE. THE
SCIENCE IS BEHIND THAT. BUT.
BUT MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS.
OBVIOUSLY I I DO WANT TO BE THE
MOST HUMANE AND I'M HOPING THAT
IT IS.
BUT.
BUT MY ISSUE HAS TO DO WITH
SMALL BUSINESSES AND THE IMPACT
ON SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND I THINK MR GRAY RAISES A
GOOD ISSUE WHICH IS.
MAKING IT A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM
WITH MONEY BEHIND IT IS IS
PROBABLY WAY TO BE ABLE TO. TO
REACH A COMPROMISE BUT IN ANY
CASE WHAT I TOLD YOU IS THAT IF
YOU CAN COME UP WITH A FUNDING.
I.
I THAT ADDRESSES ONE OF MY
BIGGEST ISSUES ON MOST OF THESE
BUSINESSES ARE SMALL MINORITY
BUSINESSES.
AND.
MOST OF THEM QUITE FRANKLY ARE
IN THE BIG CITIES AYE WHICH
SURPRISED ME. ON AND I THINK
IT'S BECAUSE IN IN IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE TAKE CARE OF
IT THEMSELVES THEY KNOW HOW TO
DO THIS KIND OF WORK BUT IN THE
CITIES THEY TAKE THEY GO TO
THESE BIGGER. FACILITIES.
OR THESE ARE URBAN FACILITIES.
SO I'M PREPARED TO SUPPORT OF
TODAY.
IT IT'S NOT IN THE BILL BUT
YEAH WE HAD A CONVERSATION AND
I'M.
TAKE YOU AT YOUR WORD.
IF IF YOU.
.
WELL AMEND YOUR BELT AND INCLUDE
THAT IN IN APPROPRIATIONS WHICH
I THINK IS WHERE IT GOES NEXT.
I I THINK THAT WOULD IT LEAST
RELIEVE THE CONCERN THE BIGGEST
CONCERN I HAVE.
AND I I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
PUTTING.
JUSTIN IN TERMS OF.
FOR FOR FURTHER REFERENCES THAT
MOM THERE'S A LOT OF A LOT OF
THINGS PUT ON BUSINESS AND A LOT
OF TIMES IT'S SOMEONE OPINION ON
WHAT BUSINESS I TO DO. AND I I
REALLY LIKE TO LOOK AT THAT GOOD
SCIENCE AND WE'RE DOING THIS
KIND OF WORK AND SO ON I'M I'M
HOPING THAT YOU'RE RIGHT THAT
THIS IS A MORE HUMANE WAY OF.
TREATING ANIMALS ON AND. I THE
REASON I SAY I THINK I LIKE THE
IDEA OF IT BEING VOLUNTARY IS
BECAUSE IF IF IN FACT THE
PRODUCERS.
FEEL LIKE IT'S MORE.
IT'S MORE HUMANE AND THAT THEY
CAN BE FUNDED.
AS PART OF THE DISH THAT CHANGE
THEN THEY'LL DO IT AND DUMB AND
THAT WOULD BE A REAL GOOD TEST
OF WHETHER I THINK WHETHER.
THAT KIND OF MOVE IS IS A GOOD
THING FOR THE INDUSTRY SO MANY
CASE THAT I I HAVE NOT ISSUED A
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE COMMITTEE
IT'S UP TO EVERYONE TO MAKE
THEIR OWN CHOICES. AND WE DO
HAVE A A QUORUM SO I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION IF SOMEONE
WANTS TO MAKE IT.
THEIR SECOND.
I'LL MAKE THE SECOND BECAUSE I
TOLD YOU I WOULD I WOULD SUPPORT
IT AT THIS POINT.
.
AND SO THEN WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALMLY RO. COME
BEALL AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS SNOW AGUIAR-CURRY FLORA
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO GRAY.
BUENO IRWIN.
IRWIN NOT VOTING.
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE SALAS
BILL PHONE CALL. SO THE BILL IS
ON CALL WE HAVE A COUPLE MEMBERS
THAT ARE NOT HERE AND SO WE'LL
WAIT AND SEE.
THANK YOU AND JUSTICE THAT
CLARIFY WE EXPECT TO WORK WITH
GROWERS AND PRODUCERS AND. AN
INDUSTRY IT SHOULD THIS BILL
PROCEED WE'D BE WORKING WITH THE
INDUSTRY GOING FORWARD EVERYONE
WILL BE AT THE TABLE THANK YOU I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU.
SO WE HAVE ONE MORE BILL YET AND
IT IS.
MR GARCIA'S BILL AND
UNFORTUNATELY HE'S ACROSS THE
HALL AND I'VE BEEN ASKED TO GO
OVER THERE PRESENT.
A BILL WITH THEM.
WE IT GOOD MISTER MISTER DARCY
IS HERE THANK YOU.
I WAS JUST GOING TO JOIN YOU
MOVE THE BILL SIX
SO THIS IS.
ITEM NUMBER TWO ON THE AGENDA
AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX.
MEDICARE AND.
OLLEAGUES THIS IS A BILL THAT
I THINK YOU'RE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH.
AND THAT SAID TAKING THE
EXISTING BIT PREFERENCE FROM
FIVE PERCENT TO TEN PERCENT PER
STATE PURCHASES RELATED TO
CALIFORNIA GROWN.
OR CALIFORNIA PACKED AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTS OVER THOSE PRODUCED AT
A STATE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THAT AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
HERE THE RUSSIAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU AND WE
ARE. CERTAINLY SUPPORTIVE OF AB
TWENTY ONE OF SIX WE THINK MR
GARCIA FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
EFFORT. AND WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE CHAIRS THE
LAST YEAR EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWO AND WE THINK THAT THIS BILL
BUILDS UPON THAT SUCCESS TO
ALLOW FOR GROWERS TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE C. PROCUREMENT PROCESS.
AND CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
PROWESS ISN'T SOMETHING I FEEL
LIKE WE NEED TO SHARE THIS
COMMITTEE YOUR WELL ACQUAINTED
NOW THAT. I'M BUT IT'S ALWAYS
IMPORTANT TO MENTION THAT
CALIFORNIA GROWERS DO MORE WITH
LESS THAT'S BECOME A STANDARD IN
IN THE STATE. AND OUR GROWERS
HAVE THE HIGHEST
AND ENVIRONMENTAL LABOR WAGE AND
FOOD SAFETY STANDARDS ACROSS THE
BOARD AND AND SO. WE DO ASK THAT
JUST AS THE STATE HAS RECOGNIZED
THAT THEY. ARE INVESTING IN
CLIMATE SMART BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR CALIFORNIA
STATE AND ZERO EMISSION LOW
EMISSION VEHICLES FOR STATE
FLEET. OTHER SHOULD ALSO ALSO
MAKE THAT PRIORITY FOR
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY COMMENTS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ACTUALLY I THE QUESTION
GENERALLY I LIKE TO SEE
SOMETHING.
IMPLEMENTED BEFORE WE INCREASE.
THE PRICE AND AND FIVE PERCENT
SEEMED LIKE A PRETTY. OF
REASONABLE.
MARGIN BETWEEN YOU KNOW TO
ENCOURAGE A CALIFORNIA PRODUCE
BUT CAN YOU EXPLAIN.
BESIDES A FEW FARMERS HAVE
REACHED OUT AND SAID IT'S
DIFFICULT IS THERE ARE THERE ANY
STATS THAT IT MUST BE TEN
PERCENT MAKE THIS.
.
VIABLE.
I CAN SPEAK TO THE FARMERS IN
OUR DISTRICT.
THE IN WHICH WE FIND OURSELVES
BOTH ADJACENT TO ANOTHER
COUNTRY.
AND OTHER STATE AND THE FACT
THAT THE THE COMPETITIVENESS.
THAT OCCURS BETWEEN THE AG
INDUSTRIES IN THESE TWO
PARTICULAR AREAS OF THE FIVE
PERCENT.
THEY FELT.
COULD NOT.
POSSIBLY MEET SOME OF THE.
WHAT THEY REFER TO AS?
SPILL OVER.
AFFECTS OF HAVING AG.
PRODUCED DIDN'T STATE OF
ARIZONA AND IN MEXICO AND AS YOU
KNOW OUR DISTRICT IS ADJACENT TO
THE MEXICAN BORDER OF ALEX EQUAL
MICKEY KILEY WHICH IS. A CITY OF
ABOUT A MILLION PLUS PEOPLE AND
AG IS ONE OF THE BIG INDUSTRIES
IN THAT AREA AS WELL ALSO.
TRYING TO MAKE THEM.
MORE COMPETITIVE IN OUR REGION
THAT WAS ONE OF THE OBJECTIVES
HERE.
OKAY. ANYONE ELSE.
YOU MAKE INCLUDE.
RESPECT LAST RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS DOES
EYE INJURY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SO I'LL ENTERTAIN
MOTION.
OVERHEAD MOTION SECOND OKAY WILL
TAKE THE ROMAN.
AB ONE TWENTY ONE OH SIX IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS KILEY RO
AYE OF URAL I MATHIS.
AGUIAR-CURRY FLORA GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE IRWIN.
AND WHEN I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE SALAS
BILLS BECAUSE THE BILL IS ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO.
WHEN WE TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS HEARD EARLIER
WHICH IS AB TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
ABOUT BY SOME THE MEMBER BIGELOW
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THAT.
SIR SECOND.
THERE'S A SECOND.
THE ROLE PLACE.
AB TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN THE
MOTIONS TO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
CABALLERO AYE CUMBIA AYE MATHIS
AGUIAR-CURRY FLORA. GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE LEVINE SALAS.
ON COM. GOES ON CALL.
AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NUMBER
RODRIGUEZ.
WE NEED EMOTION. WE NEED A
MOTION ON THAT ONE.
RICK RODRIGUEZ.
THERE WAS.
THERE IS A MOTION IS OUR SECOND.
I NEED A SECOND.
TO WRITE.
THEY'RE ALL PLEASE.
IN AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY DO
PASSED FOR APPROPRIATIONS KILEY
ARE AYE CUMBIA AYE MATHIS.
AGUIAR-CURRY FLORA. GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GRAY.
I GRAY AYE IRWIN.
BERMAN I JONES SAWYER UP JONES
SAWYER AYE LEVINE SALAS ON.
THE BILL IS ON CALL. THE NEXT
ITEM IS AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA.
I NEED A MOTION.
SO THAT.
BUSH HAS BEEN MADE AND SECONDED
TO REPLACE.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY A.
DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS CAVIAR
OWN AYE COME WE ARE ALL AYE.
THIS
I YEAR CURRY FLORA. GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GRAY.
I'VE GRAY AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE LEVINE SALAS.
THE BILL IS ON CALL. AND A. THE
LAST ONE THAT REQUIRES MOTION IS
AB TWENTY NINE OH NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
I ALL. AND THERE'S A MOTION IS
OUR SECOND.
THERE'S A SECOND.
AB TWENTY NINE OH NINE DO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMEY ROI CLUB
WE ARE ALL AYE MATHIS.
AGUIAR-CURRY. FLORA. GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE LEVINE SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
THOSE ON CALL THAT CONCLUDES.
I'M SORRY AWARENESS OUT I'M IT'S
OUT.
WELL BUT WE NEED.
WE STILL NEED.
WE ONE WITH THE BILL IS ON CALL
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA.
WE'RE GONNA GO AND DIE. OR
GONNA ASK THE ABSENT. FROM HER
SCHOOL.
I APPRECIATE THAT BUT.
.
THAT WE'RE GONNA CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SO THAT THEY CAN ADD ON
AND I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
THAT WAS HERE TODAY REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU SHOWING UP IN AND
VOTING COULD WE HAVE WE HAVE
SOME BILLS ON COSTA.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR AB
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO A. B. THIRTY
TO FIFTY TWO AND AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY.
AGUILAR KERR.
FLORA. LEVINE SALAS. SALAS SIDE.
AB TWENTY ONE OH SIXTY PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS MATHIS.
AGUIAR-CURRY FLORA. LEVINE
SALAS.
SALAS SIGH.
MORE. REALISTIC.
NBI ONE NO SIX LARA.
NOT VOTING.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AGUIAR-CURRY FLORA.
FLORA I.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR LEVINE.
LEVINE I.
ON AB TWENTY ONE NO SIX.
MATHIS AGUIAR-CURRY LEVINE.
EQUIPMENT.
AB TWENTY ONE US SIX.
LEVINE I.
I KNOW YOU HAVE MARK.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I.
YES.
A. B..
TWENTY ONE OH SIX.
MATHIS AGUILAR CURRY.
A YEAR CURRY I.
AB TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN MATHIS.
AGUILAR CURRY. A YEAR CURRY AYE
FLORA.
FLORA AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE SALAS.
YES I.
SALAS AYE NOW.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY DO PASSED
TO A PROBES MATHIS.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN.
AGUIAR-CURRY I FLORA.
FLORA AYE LEVINE.
FOR SIX.
LEVINE AYE SALAS AYE SALAS AYE.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT DO
PASTOR PROBES.
MATHIS.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
A YEAR CURRY AYE FLORA. FLORA
AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE SALAS. SALAS AYE.
AB TWENTY NINE OH NINE MATHIS.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
A YEAR CURRY AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I.
AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY NINE
AGUIAR-CURRY. A YEAR CLEARING NO
FLORA.
LARA KNOW LEVINE.
LEVINE NO.
SALAS.
SALAS SNOW BILL FAILS.
OKAY THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING
TODAY THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED AND.
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED